foreign
there are more humans trapped in slavery
today than any other time in history
it makes you think
why the media most of them and also some
people in Hollywood do not want to talk
about this more than one in five victims
of sex trafficking are children
by some estimates 4.8 million people are
trapped or forced into sexual
exploitation globally
ask yourself why don't they want us to
see it what are they hiding
this video is going to open your eyes to
the truth
what you need to do is decide whether
you want to live in the truth or in a
made-up false world where evil controls
what you think and believe
let me give you an example
the movie The Sound of freedom is an
amazing film by Angel studios and is
based on a true story of child sex
trafficking
it's about Tim Ballard a federal agent
played by Jim Caviezel who decided to
quit his job and leave his pension in
order to save innocent little children
used as sex slaves
now after you've watched this powerful
amazing movie it gives you the following
facts
there are more humans trapped in slavery
today than any other time in history
including when slavery was legal
millions of these slaves are children
human trafficking is a hundred and fifty
billion dollar a year industry this is
insane just so you have an idea of how
big an industry this is
Coca-Cola they're across the whole globe
right they only have around 40 billion a
year that's how much they make and then
when you look at McDonald's they have
around 20 billion a year
150 billion industry
that's trafficking
and the US is one of the top
destinations for human trafficking and
is among the largest consumers of child
sex
this is sickening the U.S is one of the
top destinations in the world for
trafficking it makes you think
why the media most of them and also some
people in Hollywood do not want to talk
about this and if they do they're
negative about this they want to
discredit this movie
why ask yourself
because no rational
human being with good values good morals
will be against this
unless they agree with what is happening
they want it to happen and they
themselves are hiding something
watch this
these films are created out of moral
panics they're created out of bogus
statistics they're created out of fear
and with something like sound of Freedom
it specifically is looking at keyword on
concepts of these child trafficking
rings that are run by the high level
Elites here's how the media received at
Washington Post sound of Freedom as a
box office hit whose star Embraces Q
Anon Rolling Stones sound of freedom is
a superhero movie for dads with brain
worms the guardian sound of Freedom the
Q Anon adjacent Thriller seducing
America for some reason the entire media
is smearing this movie as a dangerous
conspiracy theory
the Press is saying that the star Jim
Caviezel is a q Anon guy
and Jim plays Tim Ballard which is
strange because just a few years ago the
same media was celebrating Tim Ballard's
heroics watch
Tim Ballard has one mission to track
down child traffickers four months ago
Colombian authorities asked him to
investigate a tip that children were
being sold there as sex slaves within a
half hour
this individual walks up to me starts
asking me what I'm here for what I want
and within minutes he says well I've got
I've got kids as young as 11 years old
as we said we none of us heard of this
movie and you would have only heard of
this movie if you are a regular among
Church groups or you regularly watch Fox
News or you follow right-wing
personality like Ben Shapiro and Jordan
Peterson and the like or you are a q a
non-conspiracy theorist or part of the
so-called Freedom movements
this movie is a powerful movie that is
showing you the truth of what has
happened what is happening and what will
continue to happen if we don't do
anything about this
and the media had that to say
they're showing their true colors
you need to stop supporting these kind
of people there are powerful people
behind the scenes controlling certain
media groups certain people in Hollywood
and they don't want you to know the
truth
and you know Tim spoke to the Senate
years ago watch this
for the last five years
as chairman Graham mentioned I served as
the founder and CEO of the
anti-trafficking organization operation
Underground Railroad working hand in
hand with law enforcement
in 20 countries including 22 States in
this country
operation Underground Railroad has
rescued over 2 000 victims and assisted
in the arrest of over 1 000 traffickers
and pedophiles
much of my work has been based on simple
economics
the United States is one of the highest
if not the highest consumers of child
pornography in the world we are the
demand for child sex
as such traffickers around the world
seek to bring children to the United
States where they can sell them for sex
and make a lot of money
my number one personal and professional
goal has been to keep these children out
of the hands of these sick American
pedophiles
I want to share one case in which we
failed to do this
the victim was a foreign-born child
around 12 years old who we will call
Lily
Lily was kidnapped South of the Border
she was then taken along with several
other children her age and smuggled into
the United States not through a Port of
Entry but rather through a report
through a part of the Southern border
without significant barriers
or a wall
lilies traffickers easily transported
her to New York City where she
was raped between 30 and 40 times a day
and this is not atypical at all for a
case like this she believes that she
alone was raped over 20 000 times
between the age of 13 and 17 right here
in our country
shame on them
shame on those people who did it in
shame on those people out there right
now who are trying to discredit
what happened
who are trying to discredit this movie
let's build on truth on facts and you
know three years ago Hollywood rejected
this movie they didn't want you to see
this
listen to the producer did you expect
this kind of response it has been a a
Groundswell Across America I just
reacted to what that last two weeks have
been like with your amazing film
of course of course not I mean uh we
spent eight years of our lives in
putting this movie together
and I never imagined especially when you
finish the film uh almost three years
ago and then you were knocking doors
everywhere and all the experts in
Hollywood told us that this is not a
good film for them that nobody will
nobody will go see this film so after
three years of uh rejection you have two
options either you give up or you don't
give up and which you know we choose the
second one and after praying to God for
a miracle to happen for this film please
send an angel to rush with this film
Angel Studios rescue this film and
because of them millions of people are
seeing this film in this 10 days more
than 5 million people show up in
theaters and I I can't believe that this
is happening this is like I feel like
I'm dreaming evil is working behind the
scenes and you know they've been working
in the entertainment industry for a long
time now just look back these last few
decades just look at how much
entertainment industry has changed think
about what your kids are watching today
compared to what you want when you grew
up it's because through entertainment
they know that they can influence people
especially young innocent Minds as
vulnerable
they want to change what people are
thinking about life itself what the new
normal is
and you know there are good people out
there with good values good morals that
that has great shows
but they don't want it out there
they want to control what people see so
that it can control what they think
you know I was very sad because I wanted
to come out in theaters three years ago
and it was not happening and then maybe
a year later okay this is the time now
and nothing happens and of course I was
sad my investors were calling me Eduardo
what's going on a lot of pressure from
all my investors I have a lot of
investors a lot of people that believe
in this project and now I'm responsible
I'm the producer I'm calling Alejandro
the director and he's called me every
day what's going on what's going on and
I'm just bleeding because I I show the
film to the people and the people cry
the people you know they stand
Innovations but the experts are saying
no this is not for us so of course of
course you get confused because you
don't know really what what do you have
in your hands but you know what when you
are waking up every day and you know
that you're using your talents your
projects to save lives
you know what you can stay 20 years 40
years for that one child because that's
that's the exercise that I do every day
I close my eyes every day in the morning
what if this is my song what if my
daughter is missing what would I do I
will stop everything that I'm doing and
I will give my life to to find my child
well that's my motivation I'm waking up
every day to fight for for children to
Angel trafficking I don't want to wait I
don't want to wait for this tragedy to
come to my life for me to wake up I want
to wake up now a lot of you need to wake
up right now and maybe this movie can
start this whole movement because there
are secret societies
and evil is working within them and
through them
in B corporations
governments
school systems
social media companies
and certain news media
they didn't want this movie to get out
there in the first place and now that it
is out there they can't stop it but
still they are trying to they're trying
to discredit it ask yourself why why
don't they want you to see this movie I
mean this is the worst kind of evil
little children innocent children
ask yourself why don't they want us to
see it what are they hiding
media
Hollywood
those secret societies
watch this
Elijah Wood shocking allegations against
the entertainment industry in a new
interview with the Sunday Times the
former Child Star alleges that
pedophilia has been a real issue in
Hollywood he tells the publication quote
there are a lot of vipers in this
industry people who only have their own
interest in mind what bums me about
these situations is that the victims
can't speak as loudly as the people in
power that's the tragedy of attempting
to reveal what is happening to innocent
people they can be squashed but their
lives have been irreparably damaged but
there is Hollywood's other dirty secret
that victimizes the most vulnerable
children and someone who's spoken out
about this and is painfully aware is
former Child Star Corey Feldman
freeze you're in shock I mean children
aren't supposed to handle that sort of
stuff
I can tell you that the number one
problem in Hollywood was and is and
always will be pedophilia nobody talks
about pedophilia it's the big secret
then it's widespread oh yeah
I was surrounded by them and Jeff asked
whether Weinstein's Behavior was an open
secret in Hollywood
I think there was knowledge amongst a
certain group of people mostly who did
business with with with Harvey Weinstein
there are countless women who understood
that that's what happened and there were
many people who said well that's just
Harvey being Harvey how serious is it is
it about one person one man or is it a
culture you and I and even the likes of
the people on the Turner Classic Movies
understand that the idea of the casting
couch that existed in Hollywood is the
part of both myth and concrete reality
they would go to the auditions and so
forth to try to pick the ones that they
wanted at one point he said uh you know
what why don't you just take off your
clothes take off your clothes and let me
see what you look like you've their
faces one alleged victim had roles in
What's Eating Gilbert Grape and the
Apostle another is an aspiring musician
who was violated when he was just 11
years old
meet Evan hensing he is just one of five
telling their stories in the documentary
and Open Secret the 21 year old says he
was abused for five years by his manager
Marty Weiss who was convicted for his
sex crimes on Evan in 2012. do you
remember that first
time yeah yeah I do what happened we
went to the park and we played
basketball so it was that
[Music]
night he touched me at 11 I didn't know
it was improper it just didn't make any
sense to me but Evan may not be the only
one the manager also allegedly abused
the late Corey Haim and Corey Feldman
Feldman told us it didn't in there when
I look back at a picture of when I was
15 years old and I was surrounded by
five men and every one of those men in
that photograph is a pedophile
that's a pretty big problem I was
molested and I said yes
I allowed it to happen
but I was a child I was told that this
is everyday business and he made me feel
like I have to do that in order to get
any job he was just saying this was
common in the industry he said oh if you
have sex with me then we'll go to Sea
World the next day when did you finally
decide I have to tell someone
at 18. I tape recorded an hour-long
conversation and I asked him
straightforward why did you abuse me and
how did he respond he responded and said
that
you were coming on to me at 12. there is
an evil sickness Within These secret
societies working within them and
through them they come straight from the
devil who wants to cause as much pain
and suffering in this temporary World
while he still has time
these people they worship the devil
their father
John 8 44 you are of your father the
devil and your will is to do your
father's desires he was a murderer from
the beginning and does not stand in the
truth because there is no truth in him
when he lies he speaks out of his own
character
for he is a liar and the father of Lies
you know my heart goes out to all the
victims especially the children even
your children being brainwashed
in schools through the media and through
the entertainment
the things they watch and the games they
play and also these children who are
being trafficked millions of them
these are innocent little children
this is sick this is evil
Pure Evil and you know these pedophiles
are smiling
because a lot of people out there part
of the media Hollywood are trying to
discredit this movie
and they're laughing
Tim Ballard joins me now so Tim why is
the media hating this movie
you know I can't understand it the film
was made produced written like five
years six years ago way before anyone
heard the name kiwanana I still don't
even know what Q Anon is uh in the
meantime they're trying to connect it to
some conspiracy when in fact like you
said this is a true story these are real
kids I mean I'm these kids are my
friends they're young adults now the
ones who are rescued they're going to
come out soon and tell their story it's
going to be very awkward when the
mainstream media comes after these kids
next and accuses them of being part of
some conspiracy when in fact they were
rescued from a life of rape it's it's
the most bizarre thing I've ever seen in
the media perhaps I mean this
publication says the sound of freedom is
a superhero movie for dads with brain
worms and that it fetishizes the torture
of its child victims is that what the
movie does
it absolutely does not do that it tells
a story based in truth and you know what
I think is happening Jesse I think that
the left and these these media Outlets
they don't want to have a discussion
that this film is going to compel a
discussion about why 85 000 children
showed up unaccompanied at the border
and got released into the interior of a
country that is uh the highest consuming
country for child exploitation material
on the planet they don't want to talk
about why the same Publications are
pushing an agenda to change the word
pedophile to minor attracted persons in
order to normalize sexual activity with
children I think that's what they're
trying to avoid and they know this
film's Gonna Shine a Light on all of the
things all the atrocities happening in
children and so they have to discredit
it by lying about it
these people are evil no wonder they're
trying to spread lies to discredit this
movie but you know what
they cannot stop God you know God is
light and he shines his light on
Darkness on the evil and it is coming to
light
and look what he did through Tim Ballard
it is amazing saving these children
listen to what the producer said you
know you know what I think why this is
uh touching so many hearts because
there's millions of people praying for
this film I believe in the power of
prayer and a lot of people are praying
for this film so this film can touch
Hearts so they speak this movie can put
pressure in government so government
once and for all I hope that they will
do something because they have the power
to end this especially in America you
have the most powerful country in the
world you have the money the technology
the Army the intelligence everything how
come we don't finish this problem
because it's not a priority you know we
need to support and pray for projects
like this they need our help so share it
far and wide with everyone and you can
pay it forward if you have the money
then you can pay it forward so that
other people can go and watch it so that
they can go and claim their free ticket
online
we need to overcome evil with good we
need your help because there will always
be people evil
who want to stop this
for example
The Washington Post said
Q Anon and sound of Freedom both rely on
tired Hollywood tropes
and Forbes said the adrenochrome
conspiracy theory pushed by sound of
Freedom star explained
you know it's the same thing over and
over they use the same things whenever
you want to speak the truth they label
you or I to conspiracy theory
and aren't you getting tired of this
here is Tim Ballard's own response if
the truth of human trafficking and child
trafficking and child exploitation
exploitation were to be brought to bear
and brought to light then they would
have to have a debate a discussion that
they don't want to have about again
these policies around sexualizing
children or allowing children to consent
at a young age to do anything and
everything which would eventually
include being you know identifying as an
adult perhaps and having sex with
pedophiles I hunt pedophiles I've been
hunting them for 20 years and they are
watching this and they're salivating
they are happy that Rolling Stones and
the guardian are ripping on a movie that
exposes them so I don't like the fact
that these media Outlets are in fact
wittingly or unwittingly running
interference for human traffickers and
pedophiles that's ridiculous that's
ridiculous you know they should
apologize to all these kids who will
rescue they should apologize to them and
they should apologize to all these
people who rescue their lives to tell
their Story I mean it it's it's amazing
I mean uh
what can I say you know I'm just so
grateful these guys are lying but
somehow because of their lies
people are waking up so they're helping
us I mean the the the numbers are
showing up that you know
um we're doing good so whatever they're
doing hey keep doing because of your
lies people who love truth now they're
responding but this but you know they
should apologize because it's not fair
these guys are are lying these are the
mainstream liberal media who they don't
care about children they don't care
about saving children they don't care
about anything they care about just
themselves and perhaps maybe some of
them I I don't know I don't have the
evidence but it's really weird
suspicious that someone doesn't want
this film to be seen by many a film that
is designed to save children and and
they're blocking maybe they're involving
the crime maybe maybe they are the
pedophiles maybe this is the guys who
are hurting these children I don't know
you know go figure
you need to be very careful and not
listen just blindly and follow what the
media is saying and what celebrities are
saying in Hollywood they are controlled
by people so they're just spewing lies
you need to understand this just because
they're celebrities doesn't mean that
they have some special knowledge or
there's something special they're just
human beings like you and me you need to
follow the truth and stick to the truth
because it is only the truth that will
set you free and if you know the truth
it is easy to discern when someone is
telling a lie trying to control how you
view the world
the devil is working hard behind the
scenes
1 Peter 5 8 says be sober minded Be
watchful your adversary the devil prowls
around like a roaring lion seeking
someone to devour
now the devil and his demons are in this
temporary world and they're doing their
best to bring out the most evil Acts
of us human beings because of our sinful
flesh that I bring the worst of our
sinful flesh out and it causes so much
pain and suffering and yes they are in
the world and they are going to do what
they're gonna do
but that doesn't mean that you should
just sit back and do nothing
because then evil will take over when
good men like you and me sit in our
comfort zones and do nothing
God is looking
for good men and women to stand up to
say Here I Am use me to shine light on
Darkness on evil to overcome evil with
good is looking for people who will do
it through the spirit because we know if
we're acting through the spirit then
we'll act within the will of God and we
will have no fear because the word of
God says that he has not given us a
spirit of fear but of power of love and
self-control
and that is what Tim did he raised his
hand
and he overcame evil with good and I
want you to listen to this to what Jim
Caviezel said on the daily wire while he
said next
to Tim
and one of the things that hit me with
the screenplay was it was very biblical
to me in the fact where you have a guy
that literally
um goes and and finds this little boy
and the little boy just asks him from
Homeland Security asks him hey you know
gets get gets information but the little
boy asks him hey will you save my sister
and he has to make a decision and that's
where we are as a country right now can
you what kind of decision would you make
if God came to you we ask God and pray
all the time but God does come to us and
ask us here it is what are you going to
do about it and so Tim essentially with
the help of his wife sold everything he
had to go and find this little girl and
I know there are many stories in the
Bible about stories like this the rare
rare this this uh this uh Ms Rojas I
keep bringing this up Miss Mrs Full
House on April 26th
give sworn testimony okay and from the
house committees and and and says that
we are uh uh 850 000 children have gone
missing right 850 next day in the media
nothing
and this continually happens all the
time why does that continue to happen
and you feel like there's some sort of
criminal Syndicate going on here and I'm
praying that a lot of these guys are in
these three letter agencies a lot of
these young guys that know a lot will
come forward and start telling the truth
and this film has the power that you
feel in your heart okay
that that I'm not afraid of evil I'm not
afraid of evil anymore I'm gonna go out
I'm gonna do the right thing come hell
or high water no there is a fight
between good and evil and there is a
line being drawn into sand that is
becoming more clearer every day
and I'm gonna say I'm gonna say
something that's going to be shocking to
you but I I need you to listen because
evil is out there working in the world
but it might also be working in you
if you watch pornography
hear me out you might not have a sex
slave but the porn industry does use sex
slaves a lot of them underage
and if you continue to watch porn you
are helping these people evil people to
stay in business
according to human trafficking
search.org traffickers can sell sexual
photos of the woman in addition to
forcing them into prostitution at a
great financial gain and the younger the
girls the more expensive the photos
making the underground child pornography
industry one of the most lucrative
markets for six traffickers
according to fight the new drug by some
estimates 4.8 million people are trapped
or forced into sexual exploitation
globally
more than one in five victims of sex
trafficking are children
of domestic minor trafficking victims
who had been forced into porn production
the average age they began being filmed
was 12.8 years old
man you know I'm I'm shaking here
this is just pure evil
in one survey 63 percent of underage sex
trafficking victims said they had been
advertised or sold online
do you get it
it's about demand and supply
if there's no demand there'll be no
Supply
if there are millions of people being
trafficked and there are millions of
people who want them to be trafficked
want to have sex slaves this is
disgusting think about how many evil
people there really are in the world and
the devil is laughing
sick pedophiles and people looking at
porn as well
you think there's no connection of
course there is
and then you know I can't just
I can't believe that there are so many
people out there who want
who wants to look at little kids naked
molest them and rape them
it is disgusting
it is sick there is a sickness within
humans and it is called a fleshly nature
and some have given themselves over to
their fleshly desire so much so that
they they've seared with a hot iron
their conscience so they don't even care
about it anymore they don't care about
these innocent little children
1 Timothy 4 verse 1 says now the spirit
expressly says that in later times some
will depart from the Faith by devoting
themselves to deceitful spirits and
teachings of demons through the
insincerity of liars whose consciences
are seared
and Romans 1 verse 28 says and since
they did not see fit to acknowledge God
God gave them up to a d based mind to do
what ought not to be done these people
in powerful positions want to hide their
sin where it festers and grows and it is
time that you shine your light and
expose them and if there are people who
are struggling with porn addiction then
please watch this video here and will
definitely help you out and if you are
curious about how these evil people want
to control the world and are controlling
the world then watch this video here and
I'll see you there and always remember
that life is short so don't waste yours
where you live in darkness or you're
sitting on the sidelines
Church guys
[Music]